hey David you talk a lot about believing
women but what would you do if you were
falsely accused of sexual assault let's
discuss it this actually came up when I
was on remember that show I went on in
LA
the Jesse Lee Peterson show we were
talking about the Brett Kavanaugh
hearings and he asked me in some way
would you want to be accused of a sexual
assault you didn't commit and I said
that's not really a question Jesse no
one I don't I don't want anyone accused
of a crime that they didn't commit of
course and in fact there was a movement
to do this at a time when I was covering
the Cavanagh hearings I started hearing
from people who said David we're going
to go to your local papers we are going
to claim that you sexually assaulted
someone and my understanding is that
some of those allegations were actually
made and they went nowhere because they
obviously were not credible but let's
answer the question as asked false rape
or sexual assault allegations are very
rare but when they happen they should be
punished and I've said that for a very
long time but let's play it out what
would I do if I were accused of sexual
assault or rape and I had not done
anything wrong
first and foremost I would say nothing
and I would immediately call a lawyer
now I know that that already puts me in
a position of privilege right not
everybody can afford a lawyer well if
the police want to talk to you if you
are being compelled to talk to them then
you can request a lawyer and if you are
not being compelled to talk to them then
I simply would not talk to them but I
would immediately reach out to a lawyer
I would not attempt to contact the
accuser I would not attempt to contact
the accusers family I would immediately
think to myself who might be able to
either provide an alibi or be a witness
in some way I would immediately try to
put in writing whatever interactions I
may have had in my life with the accuser
if there are any if it's genuinely
someone I don't even know I would of
course not have any interactions to
write down but if it is someone that is
known to me I would immediately put in
writing interactions I would check
social media records I would check email
whatever and and really categorize for
myself what the interactions have been
if any now I get it
false allegations anytime
that you have a system that allows
people to make a complaint that they
have been victimized by someone else
there will be some percentage of either
straight-up false allegations or
mistaken identity problems where an
accuser believes it was this person when
in reality it was that person what I I
really want to state here is I'm glad to
answer the question about what I would
do these are not common situations I
don't want to give them more importance
than they deserve I believe it is a far
bigger problem for those who are
victimized by sexual assault or rape to
never have justice done to the
perpetrator that is a far bigger problem
mathematically than false rape
allegations most importantly the most
important thing that I do in order to
avoid allegations of any kind is I don't
sexually harass or assault people which
in 99.99 whatever percent of the cases
is actually your best insurance if I'm
missing something if the actions I would
take are not the right ones let me know
what I'm missing we have a great bonus
show coming up for you today
of course the Friday bonus show hosted
by producer Pat and he will be telling
you about next week's plan with
Thanksgiving upcoming and much much more
so make sure you are a member at join
pakman.com or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show Pat will speak
to you then I'll be back on Monday